welcome podcast ville podcast land or
whatever you consider yourself the
Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by nature box nature box
has over a hundred snacks that taste
good and actually better for you all
snacks are made from high-quality simple
ingredients which means no artificial
colors flavors sweeteners and especially
no guilt so you can feel good about what
you're eating and right now today nature
box is offering you the Church of what's
happened now family 50% off your first
order
when you go to naturebox.com/tyler why
that's nature box calm
for 50% off your first order nature box
calm
who's better than nature box nobody
check that [__] mealy
you
are you crazy or what readings my
brother how are you this evening
I'm good am I crazy though you're asking
don't know how good was that [__]
cure we people don't know we just
watched about 20 minutes of Skynyrd and
almonds and stones but that Skynyrd
[__] still in my head right now it's
I tell people when they're confused to
just put that on and think about the
scenario I want you to think it's
Oakland it's not Kentucky it's not
Nashville
it's Oakland it's a seven I gave one
Oakland so it's a stadium it's 1977 they
were at their peak Lenox get it
it's a stadium so it's part of those
days they did tours in the summers when
I was a kid like the first show you ever
see Skinner no I saw Ted Nugent with
Aerosmith Frank Marino mahogany rush
Toto and somebody else that's the first
show I ever went to at the Meadowlands
we walked there and walked [__] back
I could hear Ted Nugent's guitar on the
walk home on the [__] Turnpike crazy
cuz we left early because one of the
guys is getting sick on the ass we're
like a [__] 700 well that's like a
throwaway like oh yeah we were on acid
where a lot of my friends had tickets
for Skynyrd at the garden before they
died like two weeks or a week before
they died I never made the game no they
were opening for Ted Nugent but they
were about to get switched they were
about that and I we've had this
discussion on eight years ago and I
always tell people seriously what would
have the turn been if scan it would have
lived if Skynyrd would have lived there
would have been no cars all those bands
would never survive in the early
eighties they couldn't they couldn't get
that [__] Skynyrd was about to take and
then Zeppelin dies so what Zeppelin goes
down get it is right there with the
[__] stones racking up cuz well I I
didn't know - you played to me that
Skinner to open up for the stones it's
gonna open up for the stones at the
festival and that's when the word got
out listen those [__] country
[__] you don't want those
albums are [__] rocks rock solid yeah
the first two the first two is special
now where they should be where they the
doctor didn't they do those at the
famous studio no I'm wrong they did some
[__] at Muscle Shoals shows yes they did
but yeah they I don't know if they did
that out they did the albums with um I'm
trying to remember I think it was a the
guy who played keyboard with dill and
what's-his-name the pretty was Al Kooper
was that his name you know I read one of
the book so I think there was a [__]
those book Keith Richards and they taped
a lot in Tennessee and had Muscle Shoals
yeah yeah yes yes they did a lady a lot
that [__] they did uh they went down to
they did a they also didn't they show up
at Chess Records in Chicago yeah [__]
they definitely went to Muscle Shoals to
it's crazy the stones would go on tour
and they would do a club and like
Parsippany known like but keep see new
york al-kubra how kuba they would do
like to warm up some girls they did like
three shows around the country you and i
were just you know geeking out over that
we but we would have that blu-ray of all
the stones and some girls in Texas yeah
and they ripped it up on there was
nothing killer for that and people don't
know that the stones were still [__]
killer in 1980 yeah I saw them the first
time in 78 and far and a hope and up for
them and Philadelphia and I didn't even
know when I was I didn't even know what
I was getting myself into bro well you
get over saying like at that time I had
some girls and get your Yaya's out if
you want me to lie to you and tell you
the truth I had two hours by the stones
I knew sympathy for the devil and I knew
a couple of other songs but that's the
two hour but did that man that show bit
like they were tremendous he came out
with an American flag on started dancing
we were doing windowpane acid Keith
Richards was [__] sensational
just sensational he just whips it up on
all those some girls long I mean his
guitar live is so overpowering from that
little feeling saying like the way they
tuned it the way he's got that weird
people
guitar he's probably know he's got like
a weird Oakland G tuning that he uses
but
I'm confused I put that Oakland tape on
if I'm gonna go to perform and I'm a
little nervous about the show you put on
this is the CNN one the skillet one
through 77 because YouTube you mean
YouTube anywhere I am I got YouTube and
I will put that video I asked off
yesterday and look at the singer look at
the guitar player but you're totally
right they got that don't give a [__]
the whole message that they're sending
is we don't give a [__] if this is
Oakland what we're rehearsing in our
barn we're gonna rip it up like you
understand me you're never gonna hear
from us with our southern mentality that
we're never gonna give you a badge
people didn't say but there's [__] you
know your flag yeah [__] president so
nice it was like man what a madness
tremendous tremendous crazy tremendous
the whole [__] video every time I see
it I cry from home alone I'll cry
because that's the level you want to
beat there's a comic that you go out
there with his [__] belt buckle and
there's boots on and Oakland California
ssin there I will say it's there's a
little it's a little I wouldn't say
depressing but it's kind of like we're
just it's like to know that you're not
see something you're never gonna get
close to his kind of a bummer
no as a human being yeah as a human
[__] battle you think I don't I was I
was a week away from his f1 tickets
going on sale and I was ready to go I
was I had all the bases covered I had
all the albums I had in through the out
door we were ready to go they were ready
to announce it and all of a sudden
[__] bomb dies no a wind got taken
out of me I was at muffin Joe's a little
sandwich joint behind Maguire Chevrolet
of Kelly Boulevard it was owned by for
Farrow and Joe jumper laughing Joe's so
[__] I going in and had the best
Taylor ham and egg in the [__] state
of New Jersey and that's why I was when
I got the
in my heart almost Brooklyn I don't
remember I don't know I wasn't around
but the second he died they just they
suspended right then yeah they said it
was over
yeah me I should have nobody nobody
really knew at first Robert Plant went
solo and he did a [__] great tour
October December 9th 1983 me
ferny bosses sudo went out into the
garden on a Tuesday night and saw a
[__] Robert Plant with Phil Collins
playing the drums oh yeah so Collins
used to play nothing a lot of crazy yeah
he used to go on tour with crazy people
Phil Collins and that how that one al by
Robert Plant the first two solo albums
do you guys try to memorize this stuff
like you know like you can memorize song
I lived it
so what's not like a piece of history i
memorize you just know it no you you
[__] live it I lived all this [__]
I just know I don't know what I'd do if
I had tits Zeppelin tickets a week
before no no I didn't have the tickets
tickets were about to go on sale okay in
those days this is how they did it
you mailed your tickets in your money
and there was no lines there was nothing
that was not what was it what was the
Boston movie this one missing
yeah were they they they get they get
ripped off right yeah yeah they get
ripped off they had them optimizers
regard money in cash right right and
they charged up front so when they
called the the arena in Nashville they
can okay
tickets gonna be 15 1250 and 10 this is
a section of this in the amount of the
seats will never get no money and the
people would say what are you [__]
kidding me they go yeah yeah we pay we
get in full but not the positive Led
Zeppelin won't take deposit
who is that crate that's crazy manager
yeah that [__] gangster
yeah he would show up and he just it was
just like this two million dollars in
cash just put it in the [__] pen yeah
he was in on it it was not only that
time that was a great little [__]
thing they did that was nothing Zeppelin
was getting paid big money like they had
a [__] plane with a fireplace and
that bubble yeah what's that DVD that
came out actually recently that had all
[__] I don't know just two things called
Led Zepplin just that you know I'm time
out that like for CDD you grew up a
music family oh yeah oh that's all I
said what I live for yeah and it's funny
I like some of the old country stuff and
I like some of the new stuff the country
women that sing the two blondes [__]
destroy me the one angry one is [__]
sensational I get their names confused
then there's one that married that Tim
McGraw she's a [__] Savage - no faith
hill faith Hill's a savage and the other
little tiny a blonde she'll [__] your
world up with a voice I love all that
[__] but I saw that you tweeted me this
listen bro let me talk to you from the
heart here all right
all right here we go about ten years ago
I was watching TV one day in a hotel
room doing comedy and I was high as a
little girl and I started going through
channels and there was an episode of the
Hannah Montana of being a radio DJ and
faking that she was crying and she was
getting the sponge and playing on her
face and she had on the how old she was
she was a kid I was too stoned to switch
to channel and I laughed so [__] hard
she reminded me like a goofy Lucille
Ball so from that time on any time
Hannah Montana was on the kids show I
would [__] them watch it yeah I loved
her as a fan I love Miley Cyrus I don't
have a mom I'm not gonna say I'm a
haenam I've never seen him oh my god
it's true she's [__] great but anyway
I'm gonna binge-watch
and then somebody sent me something one
day they go to you know yeah they go
listen to this and it was like on you
time wasn't here on YouTube it was one
of those videos they post on your team
you gotta download something and she was
singing some stuff that's a Jolin you're
playing oh no this is what before -
Jolene yeah that he sent it to me that
it wasn't a video was an audio file I
was like who's that he goes that's Miley
Cyrus and I was like bro that [__]
girls talented something about always
rub me I just read today that her
[__] uh
her did you watch that I online nice and
when I found that Miley Cyrus was on the
side I live
I watched the Miley Cyrus video
before the UFC I think that somewhat to
a fan I am because I wanted to see her
music find Miley Cyrus season hopeless
and that live this [__] is a savage now
she's [__] good man III stick up for
when all my friends lied tell me is this
video that she did like absolutely they
did it single was still not on the top
50 and the album's flop that blaming at
this she stopped smoking pot and married
that [__] dude well that part of it
that's welcome I was trying to get ever
get back I was trying to get her to be
in a video while ago but um apparently I
found the word I god was she's quit
smoking pot chained doing student
whatever right I used to see it right
over here she used to be at this weed
store three times a week with a little
brother on North Hollywood next to the
theater yeah you gotta keep smoking that
weed and once she got off the weed
because she started dating [__] hogs
brother whatever [__] mad Max's
brother didn't know these big blonde
dudes no more I would die for you is
that it yeah yeah yeah one of them
whatever for what Miley Cyrus is no joke
as dumb as people thinking is she grew
up in that [__] Dolly Parton is a
[__] godmother yeah Oh Billy race in
Kentucky right there but bad mood bad
mood just watch them first minute a bad
mood it's a corny [__] song and I
don't know this song but watch her
perform
ah in a bag
[Music]
always
Oh
shame [__] around guys I think she
showed a [__] that killed her once you
show you a little monkey there's no no
reason to hang out no boy weren't you
sure [__] yeah once you show see you
like where's where she did it I think
she did something she got naked
somewhere that night could have killed
it - well I always talk to people don't
show your [__] monkey
cuz once they see your monkey taking the
ass they stop calling that's rule number
one guys no that was I'll tell you what
that was pretty fun good bro she does
not [__] around and that Jolene come on
that version of Charlene Jesus [__]
Christ
so no no no no no one thing about her is
everybody else shows up I mean they take
three acting classes this chick was born
with it
she could do comedy she could [__]
sing and she could [__] act
she's only what 20 that she's got more
money than God so she could take chances
and she will take chance oh she don't
give a [__] I don't think no she don't
give a [__] that's why she's so good
I'll follow this sitting there going
Jesus bug girl I gave away some
expensive [__] spy must savage he is
a savage oh yeah he tried to pick it in
naturally trying to pick up my hand once
no old day she said was she hot yeah she
was pretty yeah she's pretty as my aunt
so it's kind of you know hard for me to
say yeah I think she was hot
we all have hot answers you smell their
bras maybe like [__] again with the bra
smelling you the only one ever do that I
mean I've never smelled a bra the only
one every time he talks that was about
11 he said if my aunt's bras of my 92
and from time to time only two she
leaves I was whacking off in 92 she
leave a little hot water bottle with a
little period stick with the tube let's
lift the tube seven he's done I have
sexual pleasures another place your us I
was thinking you know I'm so why I'm so
happy to be back here if you don't mind
me saying is I was leaving because last
time I was the first time I was here I
mean I do all these all the I'm doing
Burt Burt's tomorrow I like I love all
these guys but I was when I was taking
the uber home
last time I was pretty freely Steve
stone myself for you spa all right I
ain't touchin a star how about some
reefer I'll take some weed you won't
even touch it
no ice watches we humbly star Joey
whatever you threw everything was eight
once you see that fool once you see that
video Alli what you see that video Alli
you ain't touching whatever he's
touching this is we're going deep
polenta more they just stuck to the
table like spider-man good lead those
are yours least well please like this no
but you have you're like the realest
right my three you had like I do and a
half I had nine no you didn't at three I
have two batches like two matches a two
and then matches at three so what's that
going to do that's [__] ten
this is twelve and a half and I in a 100
milligram make sure you treat cuz I did
an extra five minutes a hip escape today
at the YMCA so flop you [__]
Wendy oh don't worry about luck she's a
[__] star don't ask question you know
when I was making a point here that I
was I was I was stoned in my uber home
and um I was thinking why Doug it's so
much and getting to the point where Tom
before I was like you know we don't have
Joey Coco Diaz's in Lexington Kentucky
you know I think that's what I dug so
much about is like you know like doing I
love Burt I love Tom but like I kind of
know it like those guys I know like
there's no that's why I'm approving of
you moving to Lexington there's no
Lexington need to Joey Diaz what would I
do
I don't know but you brought it up I'm
Rogan do we do a radio show together at
Lexington wake up Lex well I don't know
if I want to move back but if you move
back I gotta move back we got a roommate
side oh my god radio show music and then
with doing a radio show in the morning
yeah mom you have my mom make us dinner
yeah yes 737-300 listen for people who
don't know you said on Rogan the other
day you don't want to stick around here
too much more - what's wrong in just two
places you think about moving and I
stopped in my tracks listen at my next
one you said Colorado or Lexington
Kentucky out of nowhere my hometown you
say you're gonna move there well my
family I have family in Paducah I have
family in Nashville and that's
in Bradford so the problem is if we move
to Bradford it's like Puerto Rico I mean
they barely got electricity you know
saying you go get coffee at the gas
station and it's like but they got
leaves chicken so oh yeah we'll leave
chicken hey they got Starbucks and they
got a big queue so I'm in the town over
but there's nothing like I have to drive
two hours to fly home
Nashville my niece lives in Nashville
really so Nashville always the problem
Nashville is um it's just growing so
[__] fast like right it's not in
front like it's not as expensive our
house it's not as expensive as LA but
it's [__] closer than you think
no I know and then you have but like
Paducah the Duke is nice but you could
in Lexington you could buy a mansion for
not much please and Lexington as soon as
I saw the Christmas what is it what is
it about less than a light in my heart
become this yeah like my anxiety goes
now that day there they had stabbed
somebody on the other side of town
there's a bad side of town in Lexington
I have wasn't aware I watch the news Lee
can you put something on that star cuz I
did what did you put on it don't worry
about it you don't mean you never
trusted you advance so now that I know
what's the matter gee my brother what we
have put on it I don't know animated
cartoons of them telling you but you
switching rappers would I think should
be a federal offense Holly cop I should
mention calling the cops in front of me
I'm 39 episodes in of hope I hold on JJ
oh my [__] god I am sorry you're not
look at me do I look like I watch TV I
downloaded it for plane rides only and
the hotel room it's the show if you
click in narcos and you look around
there's a bunch of shows now
but a friend of mine goes listen what's
that JJ he was Pablo Escobar's number
one Citterio he killed 250 people and
was responsible for 3,000 deaths and he
turns himself in they gave him seven
years
Sam Burgerville is scratching her head
going jesus [__] christ well his
lawyer [__] him over is that the right
same show I think so I don't know I'm
gonna store that's the was like the
first episode something happened right
something that will happen tremendous I
wanna watch it it's about but it's in
Spanish that I ain't got time for that
yeah you gotta read the [__] and find
Prado watch TV to read keep me either
it's a nightmare to read it but I still
read it to check up on this Spanish you
know saying I don't want them slipping
don't only shoes general public I'm
CUBAN yes right the Cuban rednecks they
got two Cuban restaurants in Lexington
how [__] crazy is that what
restaurants maybe can you look at my
uncle Joey please they got I think I may
have to go to Yelp though yeah Google's
Google to Cuban relaxing to me Cuban
restaurants in Lexington I'm sure I've
been hey there's two people I want you
know I want you to go next time you're
there to go to Joe bellona's I want you
to test out did you ever been there an
Italian place where town in Lexington
yeah it's like an old church they can
eat next to the [__] hotel next to
the comedy club
yeah I've never been to that come have a
[__] food and that little restaurant
was kind of gross yeah no he's gonna
delicious yeah yeah the guy took good
guy had guess what I had something I
don't need anywhere but to do good will
people draw everywhere for this [__] and
he was absolutely right fish and chips
why have a fish and chips it was so
yummy
sometimes they gaze at the place it's
got the good biscuits yes next to the
[__] whatever the next day they bring
you biscuits ahead if they were I told
no brainer I got the air try the the
fish and chips was dipped and it's not
that you have a buddies the fish and
chips and you get two inches of batter
yeah I don't like that no I don't like
no bad I like the day differently and it
was just crusty around the thing they it
was like two big sushi sticks of fish
and chips
with a little side salad I think you're
talking about a pizza on sounds like you
you know I don't know New York Pizza
Island [__] but I think Joe bellona's in
Lexington is real good I want you to try
it next time that's called I think
excuse my pronunciation but Brasa Bona
yeah in Old San Juan look at that they
got to [__] Cuban restaurants in
Lexington Kentucky one of the
restaurants is from a guy that sounds
like me because that's how I got turned
on took the whole Lexington experience
with my brother-in-law what the
Lexington they called my wife Renee
knows we went to a human wrestler the
guys sound just like Joey crazy I'm
gonna go I'm going there I'm going for
Thanksgiving so I'll check it out but it
was Green it was beautiful yeah the
horses I mean see they have Cuban fried
rice I don't have to look at them in
here's the deal brush up on your first a
side dish here's the deal I don't want
nobody to get offended here when I go to
a town people will ask me if I'm gonna
smoke enjoy people ask me if I'm gonna
go to a bar I'm telling you about
America okay we were walking I don't
want you to get offended jr. but Julia
when I go to any point in the country
people ask me if I want to get high if I
want to do blow women act like [__]
jerk-offs they have no respect sometimes
even normal [__] dirty old man
sometimes even shocks me when I went to
Lexington guess what people asking me
what's that if I like to come over their
house and eat dinner yeah what I like to
come over their house and their mom or
their friendly people it's a different
animal listen people give me their phone
numbers go man next time you come to
Lexington
I got a boat you could stay I'll not
leave me the [__] alone you know [__]
like that that people know in the
country saving me people want to get
home like people and do this in
Lexington
people were just listen to a [__]
podcast or invite me over their house
for their mom of Nicole and brought
their mama and get a [__] show I
don't know if it's good food but my
point is so is these and [__] with the
guys like my head here because I've
always looked for that yeah cuz that's
what I was saying like I was did I go
there
no I didn't have time I was only there
for three days but I brought like seven
phone numbers home and I stapled them
just because that's a different feeling
but that's old America hey man you don't
need to stand no hotel then I got a ban
him and his wife Luther yeah we got a
room over there
cable TV our dumbass kid little doubt
the [__] Louisa hey red you know that
type of [__] yeah you don't get that
other place oh yeah you look at and you
judge at first you go what the [__] and
then you go whoa wait a second
this is America yeah cuz that's weird
cuz that you know that's all I know is
you know born raised and Lexington and
so to me you know where you're you're
from all that New York [__] thought
that's the [__] that blows me away I
don't even understand it yeah yeah it's
a difference imagine imagine like that
where you're talking about with those
people with writing your dinner and then
to spend in that weekend in New York
playing a gig it's [__] it's like I'm
on Mars I think a lot of people humble
on from each place or just terrified of
the other like when I was gonna drive to
LA people were taught me like to not
stop in like southern towns because I'm
Jewish and like like it'd be like don't
stop for too long and be careful what
you say and oh yeah it was the nicest
like it was that it was like the most
welcoming I like experienced the entire
Drive they were even there like even the
cashiers of the gas station were nice
yes cuz you got you gotta be night you
can't [__] around those small towns let
me tell you something I'm 205 West 88th
Street raised to the 3rd grade while at
the same time I was being raised in
Union City New Jersey across the bridge
while at the same time I would spend my
some ISM under 48th Street and then in
Miami I've been away from there
officially hard I know off since 83 I
went back in 93 to try comedy I've been
gone from NASA's 1993 officially what's
that 20 sunny is
right yes for like 24 24 years I am
under New York arised which means that
even though I'm gone home to see my
family and put flowers on my mother's
grave and do the things they do I'm a
fish out of water that now you don't
feel home there anymore not at all and
as a matter of fact I like Gotham
because it's not on a Main Avenue it's
in the middle when I go to do the stand
and all the other clubs in New York like
when I go uptown comedy club whatever
that place I going on 77th Street it's
too close to the corner for me brother
and when I stand close to the corner of
the speed of the cars going by it takes
me a little while to acclimate well I
see I still [__] understand I try not
to do gigs there I can't I just can't
live in traffic here so I don't remember
the realization of people doing mangly
anymore on a [__] side street so I'll
never forget being at the stand one
night but more at the other club I'm off
for Broadway it's dirty it's 20 yards
off Broadway and having to go into a
corner Lee and it was my I think I
called you I couldn't breathe I wouldn't
tell you
I just wanted you to talk to me about
something I asked you is from white
anxiety yeah the cars moving the speed
the lights the horns the whole [__]
noise of that city I grew up in that
city and it brings back like not bad
feelings but feeling is how I used to
feel when I lived there when I was 19
desperate you know always looking for
the next [__] meal in the next pigeon
you think it kind of gives you like we
were talking before like kind of the bad
memories of the drug days and [__] like
that you know what's a bad memory and
[__] everything my mom just died
being a kid you know I would walk around
the city with something that was stolen
I would sell it in different parts of
the city there's only thing wouldn't get
traced I got a good mink I had some Jews
I'd take a minute got a couple of
diamonds had a few different Jews that
there's no paperwork they pay your cash
you gotta wait for 20 minutes because
I'm saying we don't get these [__]
stories in your Toki wait there ain't no
minks and zone that sound makes to Jews
and Kentucky you know
saying like it's a [__] those tired
they're fun memories I have a lot of fun
metric when did when did when you start
feeling this way when I land I'm cool
when I go to Jersey I'm cool when I go
to eat I see George & lubes and gear the
first night and those dudes I sum it
down a little bit it's Friday when I go
into the city he's a big shows why this
is Gotham 300 seats I can't go and then
[__] around I got no [__] material
you know so it's going to be a [__]
he said that driving down to record
every CD we ever recorded every every
show I've ever well I have four CDs we
I'm two for two
well I can it bombs and two of them
immense up well yeah well the first one
was the one you were talking about yeah
I had a question so when you got when
you do like you talked about like what
do you say when you're doing clubs like
it's training or something what's the
word use working out or something yeah
like do you do you wait for your big
material for like the big like the like
but you do see it bigger shows or no no
let's say I got three things on a piece
of paper I've been thinking about I went
to the store and I tried to I had five
to start off with but I went to the
store and I through a tool rather than
they bombed in between good stuff right
like you hide a joke and you it's a sama
fight it's a sabotage I listen for the
react so there's no reaction I try to
rewrite the attack or sometimes I just
forget it along the way so I focus on
what I have so and I have two weeks of
those so I have nowhere to go with them
I'll bring them to the ice house and
just thought this last time wasn't a
good one because I was forgot what I had
to talk about I lost my notes I put them
on a piece of paper and put him in the
back of my pocket and the next dad comes
on yeah because I mean I'd mentioned
because we're doing my show here is it's
2,000 seats and I'm like I actually
brought it up I mean I don't want to
talk about money or that [__] I was like
Naomi I wonder if like you know Joey or
somebody would open up and then it's
like my my people are just like no those
comics
you know they like Joey could play that
in his sleep he ain't can open up the
show you know I'll come down if I'm in
town December 3rd I'll look call me
tomorrow yeah well I got it you know we
got I got paid I definitely love to do a
[__] little country here here's
here's my here's my idea another up idea
for an opener just [__] spotlight
comes on
Lee takes the star eyes rolled back in
his head passes out lights off I'll have
to be like we'll have to get like a
10,000 milligram star made up or
something 300 300 bucks like I get like
a drink ticket or something yeah 2lt
want 210 drink tickets let me ask you
something brother what is your
demographic at these shows what are you
getting
that's a good question everywhere I mean
west coast is there's a little bit of
the hipsterish
I already got we got one call about um
bikers wanting to a ride down to the
show like a motorcycle guys wanna do a
ride there it's it's a R it's a it's a
cool it's becoming a cool mix of like
guys who love just crazy [__]
country fans kind of hipster dudes
bikers
we're finally getting women to show up
which is cool the first tour I did was a
[__] sausage fest beginning to end
but these are yeah these West Coast
shows sorry to keep hip at my shows but
are like our four will be our four
biggest four biggest shows I've done
it's all these are all theater shows and
we've been doing clubs for in bigger
tickets I can see I can feel it getting
bigger and these this will be a nice way
to end the year thing now when you're in
the South do you do a lot of show the
south yeah I do but I'll do I'll do
Lexington oh you know every time I'm
near near Lexington where I always you
want to put my hometown so I can see
family and [__] but I know the South has
a weird reaction to what I do because
like in Nashville's got it's like
Nashville's become very hip but also
very corporate to and I'm not really
accepted on either the corporate guys
are like [__] you with your dirty [__]
the hipsters are like you know you're
not politically correct they don't
really you know so I'm kind of
ostracized from both groups so I try not
to play Nash
when you do Louisville its Louisville is
good but it's weird because the sports
rivalry is so crazy that I'm not making
this up but like people like will just
scream you know [__] the cats I was just
like dude it's just a [__] country
show man like we'd have to like like but
that's like their whole life is Kentucky
versus Louisville and they know I'm a
Kentucky fan so like guys will just
scream [__] you know go Cardinals are
like who's into sports I mean I love
sports but like who's into it that much
to scream in it during a [__] show
you know listen I did the show so I did
a Lexington the opener was some
Louisville and he was [__] hysterical
I have to look at my phone and get his
name he uh I never saw any kind like
gundermen I was funny I've never even
been to call me on Broadway but on
Friday he did this [__] Rick Pitino a
joke and it was filthy as [__] and the
place disintegrated he blew the top off
it
he said this joke he goes this [__]
guy and he goes on my route to telling
us that dome or how did it start because
it started with him bringing a hooker
into a [__] restaurant and then
things get no worse he gets her pregnant
what the [__] is wrong with you Rick
Pitino was it you should have [__] her
in the ass and I [__] dog I almost
fainted I almost fainted had the room
blew up so I understand what you're
saying I mean that soon as he talked
about college basketball the stakes were
[__] up
it went up ears were up and they were
ready to attack jack cuz they're sitting
around all year and then I'll also
ambassador all season starts and they're
the center of the universe so it's like
the first time that they're in the
spotlight you know is it because they
have good teams like I would think the
football game would be a lot bigger
no but kit but they're football tips I
look at don't do me a favor yes sir
the Wildcats won in 1977 the NC Double
78 78 basketball I think the guys name
was Jack the goose given Jack Givens who
the [__] do you think you're dealing
with this [__] Joey bananas these
[__] think that I just fell off
heavy scored 50 something boy 42
[__] you think you're dealing with 42
this kid went off on a Monday night he
went off against Duke it was against
Duke with Mike Jim Minsky in the middle
defense before Duke was two before
though Duke was yet before Duke was Duke
this was it was uh I had written letters
to that coach Bob whatever was his name
and the title the lineup was oh he had a
good [__] team he had Mike Jim Minsky
and is the beauty about Mike German ski
Lisa at regiment's keep that he played
the finals and he was suddenly 17 years
old because he was such a [__] scour
and he hadn't already done high swear he
gradually was 12 like I'm 12 like what
they do like they made him they read
sure those four five see I never use I
didn't know the stats but I don't under
I would never in ceiling yeah yeah no
was definitely 42 made the cover of
Sports Illustrated actor goose Givens
with a [__] layup and it said [__]
Jack the goose Givens goes off against
[__] and us got those guys um you know
that's their glory days and they don't
oh my god and they don't move they come
back there and why would they yeah
people there they buy they buy car
dealerships those guys they get on
[__] sports it's a beautiful thing I
love it I love wall I think Kyle Macy
was on that given given given just put
Kentucky Wildcats championship and the
year will come up I've never seen any my
spell Givens that but there is GI AV ENS
Givens 41 these [__] think I
know pull up on the big screen for
secondly I want you to put up the dude
good-o 71 Duke starting team let me see
you off scratch it had to be gene banks
and then we didn't win it again talk
Mike German ski
I think 96 John spinner cool listen to
the starting team Lee so you know put
Duke 19 whatever they played they played
that [__] team they played the
Kentucky Wildcats see if I'm wrong Kenny
Dennard gene banks Mike German ski John
spinner cool if I can get four out of
[__] five that's a [__]
oh brother yeah I can i smoke more dope
than [__] half of no no it had to be
the neck book there was 77 78 77 okay 78
whatever the team was where's my glasses
I can't I couldn't name one of the dude
guys all I remember is Jack the goose
Givens yeah there you go yeah there it
is I was telling tea who is the starters
that's like funny
enchantra knowledge in school Uncle Mike
Jim Minsky gene banks Kenny Dennard that
I had three out of whatever Kenny
Dennard was my coach at [__] five
star basketball care now I and he used
to show up with a sweatshirt with a
skunk in the hood a baby skunk he gonna
hit me in the back as you wake up his
[__] and he shows us the [__] sky and
the next year there he is again [__]
the Kentucky I went to I went to County
basketball can't remember that guy what
was they call me sounds good
all that [__] that that was that I
learned for that [__] but I know you're
some it like that it really does it dick
it controls the town to a point where it
like will play Lexington between songs
people just are throwing cats see 80s
cats cat it's like come on man well they
live for that I like it listen pick a
house simple your wipers but this is the
thing you believe in so [__] much
yeah if you're filthy rich in those
times you donate this [__] oh yeah ain't
coordination you they give you if you
look at those really [__] envelopes
they'll make your weight [__] flip I
agree with you that they polish and
scream it out at your show but I love
going into any sporting event in Boston
I no matter who they're playing no
matter what sport it is it a Yankee suck
chant we'll start at some point and it
is it still makes me smile is I mean I
know you're saying a vet but not a
[__] music they know but it's kind of
fun just cuz it's like you know what
else they're gonna cheer you know I love
if somebody just yells and you play with
it that's what you do turn it around
to play on it yeah sometimes they they
scream [__] King which I prefer that
other that's a good one yeah house
touring Brother house you say I'm a
little bit over it to be honest as the
show's get bigger and I can you can calm
down a little bit more it's been better
um I don't know I just think it happened
a little too late for me I guess like we
were talking before like I I guys like
how you do like a but I'll do like a I
didn't do what what it's called sober
October 2 where the [__] they did like I
was like I might you know what else just
for fun I'm gonna try to stay sober to
the first two days of October I'm gonna
open up for Kid Rock at Nashville like I
can't [__] stay sober for this know
that that card that go it was great but
the crime he was actually this festival
he puts on called the Kid Rock fish fry
which is it was crazy it was like I've
never seen people like it's almost like
they wouldn't let you in without wearing
some kind of American you know American
flag apparel and you know tattooed guys
you know everyone it'll it was
debauchery but it was fun though they
really cook yeah yeah we fish there yeah
they have okay yeah though yeah they
unveiled the Kid Rock Madame Tussaud wax
Kid Rock which I guess at the Kid Rock
fish fry is a big deal but um but it was
but yeah I just you know I can't be that
I can't be sober when everyone's [__]
off their minds you know it's just weird
what everyone's staring at me and
they're like the five thousand you know
drunkest [__] dudes I've ever seen I
mean it was a fun show is just you know
it was you want to say is what do you
like to do a couple cocktails a couple
joints couple two - oh I'll do a few
beers in it
my thing is a I'll do like three beers
and a shot of bourbon and then maybe a
little bit of a little bit of weed
what's your bourbon of choice makers I
like that very much - yeah look there's
some makers if you will on the Kentucky
Bourbon
yeah but I try actually I've stopped
smoking weed before the show because I
came in my lyrics I'll wait till after
no I'll tell you what's another [__]
you have two shows and you get huh
and you carry my movie said that joke
already so you deliver the kind of line
never have to do that yeah oh my god you
gotta deliver a little timely just to
see if you said already if I until
something goes you said that already and
it hasn't happened and used to happen
late fall in Miami because there was one
of those frozen drink places across from
the improv
and it was 140 proof don't one of them
call a cab you got a drink three of them
why do you give the strongest of
everything was because we don't [__]
around here there was like an eighty
proof that was chocolate I mean they
were delicious
I for sure maybe it was like bliss only
it was 1998 it was way before the mocha
Tino and the whole thing and these
people in Miami and in South Beach wet
willies and in Charleston South Carolina
a Charleston school saying yeah they had
these free never been there that these
frozen drinks there's always chicks in
bikinis
they got [__] guns it's just like a
frozen yogurt place okay frozen yogurt
place is depressing never enough frozen
yoga my sis got girl girl keaney's and
guys two guys by this to bikinis behind
the bar they come over hey there's like
Hooters for real but where's the guns
come from I don't know I'm just
imagination
rubber because all the questions in 60
minutes and so next thing you know you
have like the different proofs then
there's this red stuff it's called
quality cabinets made with grain alcohol
and they won't give you more than three
of them
and I would go over there early drink
one maybe drink two and then while the
headliner was on after I got off I would
go back there by that time my drug
dealer would show up I put the money on
the ball he throw the napkin on the
floor and walk out I'd look around pick
up the napkin I go to wet willies get
one of those little red drinks walked at
a condo 50 yards from the comedy club I
put a lid on the [__] wet willy I put
in her refrigerator and grind up the
coke leave half of it at the condo for a
victim take the other half with me I'm
saying I got a
like the one way so those are the
touring days yeah I'm like Cosby on
rollerskates
how about that how about that giving out
yoga vision
see that sounds like that sounds like a
photo my god that was like the day's
time we walk through Coconut Grove
looking for a victim and then I would
borrow my god you were the comedian yeah
with you oh nice part of it was until
that what was it but by this time in 98
it was a [__] party
and then I didn't know it when I went
down there and one night I go I'm
starving I can't sit in this condo no
more all of a sudden it was like [__]
people all over the streets and I went
to eat I bumped into some waiters and
I'll come over here and one of them said
do you want do a blast and that was it
that became my favorite spot like I was
telling you I've never played in Miami I
never do Miami I would do a Houston that
El Paso and you develop these spots
where you know you're gonna be taken
care of you know the guy that's got the
best [__] I had all their phone numbers
and I would call him a week before I
went down there yoked I'll be that
Thursday get the party started really no
[__] can I get tickets for the shelf we
hear whatever you want just bring the
heavy [__] package or if it's a grand
or an extra two spoons for you uncle
Joey I'm running light these days they
come I give the money by the time I got
to a comedy club I had the package in my
pocket I would not do it before I went
on stage so I knew that hey whether I
was opening up for Rogan her headlining
in those days it was all I could do this
[__] I couldn't get away with here why
is that because my wife was my
girlfriend time-to-live mother her and I
lived together in Hollywood so I
couldn't go to bed with my heart
pounding out of my [__] shirt with a
victim next to me hums and she would
wake up and go you okay yeah yeah yeah
you had a couple sodas yeah if I
finished my package of two I'd go to bed
at 4:30
if I jerk ball four times and smoke the
[__] back and a half and cigarettes
shrank waddle to come down and fall
asleep before 30 but those lights I
wants to look till six she can get up
for work and bust me so I couldn't do
those nights when I went to Houston
Miami I had all my little Myrtle Beach I
still got a Myrtle Beach way back when
as soon as I got to the club this old
guy with a ponytail come up to me put
the package of my age then he come back
Sunday night paint him when I get paid
that's our what that's how fast or what
so every city was like download science
I had every city by 1998 if I went to
Michigan there was a few places in the
Bible Belt that buckling like what
Clarke Tennessee is RRL Clarke something
like that Clarke's real something
Tennessee [__] yeah that was a
Tuesday night I did in those days they
were called something there was it was
the company who managed carrot top and
they had a bunch in fact I'm working for
them in Charlotte nice people have and
those guys but at this time there were a
big management Club a big management
team they managed whatever I said and a
couple other comedians and they Haven
were the producers on that movie that
wah
what did you say what was then I made
but they had these rooms from North
Carroll in the Bible Belt and West
Virginia where miners were coming with
mascara on their eyes and all the way
down to the Bahamas if you want to go to
the Bahamas you could go with them they
still do it I think they still book it
don't pay no money or you could take
your family okay Curtis on stage why not
because has just sang up from the tail
end of the [__] you know be a helicopter
landing right next to you on the stage
they won't even let you back in your
room then go to your room and bring your
possessions to you that's how quick the
party ends well I says no I slipped out
of this it's gotta be perfectly clean it
wasn't I was coming up when I was a
[__] feature act
in 95 I was supposed to go down and a
week before that the guy I was supposed
to go down there his appendix blew up
something happened told so they had
cancer the gate and a month later I was
telling somebody the story they listen
bro you're [__] lucky and I go why
they go you have to be tip-top spotless
clean at this resort like are you
seriously goes listen they'd stop you on
stage ticket to lobby ten minutes of
helicopters they're taking you to a
[__] ship to get you to [__] too
high to forget how they had it to get
you off but they would get you off why
are they like that just because it was
something you could encourage something
there was something going on on that bar
never end up going down
how funny do you find yourself in
positions when you came in here you were
very kind to bring into out men we will
walk or Julie congratulations thanks mom
but on the label it says that you
abandoned from Walmart and somebody else
in somebody else Walmart Kmart and Best
Buy yeah you think about it this is this
is this is real country this is real
country did the lyrics are a little
[__] off but this is real country can
you just explain how the banning process
goes like like a letter that says your
visit well they said that what they said
was I needed to make like a lot all
those hip-hop Alps are there but that
they make the clip they sell the clean
versions there okay so the clean version
yeah so they told me sent us the clean
version Zygo I'm making no [__] clean
version and you can't like just sell the
dirty version they go no you're you know
you can't be sold here so I was like I
took the fucking's they said they want
me to put a you know parental guidance
sticker I go [__] that just put banned
from all those places sticker on them oh
that's because they know I on my label
you know I've run everything I own the
songs I don't have to push em I want I
want it I paid for that stickers to put
on me a band from all those stores and
um I wear it as a badge of honor you
know I don't want to you know listen if
the song if a clean song came in my head
and I wanted to sing it's not like I'm
just sitting down like trying to think
of the dirty and people come up to me
all the time like I got a song idea for
you you know
you know [__] farts I'm just like you
know I need chords here you know like
like I know I know like bad words it's
just not about the bad words okay
it's gonna be good music in good country
so like I said if a clean song can't if
a song came to me that wasn't dirty I'd
sing it I thought it's not that it's
just when you pay for it yourself I just
sing what I want to sing what I what I
the stuff I wanna sing is a [__] you
know the country you know in the old
days I just used to be nothing it wasn't
dirty but it was like it was the truth
you know nowadays the truth is um how
we're talking right now [__] [__] cause
like I just can't not I can't talk like
that and then not sing like that doesn't
makes it fun consent to be like like you
were just saying like you doing a clean
show it's like or if you you payin to do
your album and then for some reason just
tellingly you're gonna you wanna do it
clean yeah wheeler it's not like I'm a
bad businessman when I started I bought
the whole thing of hook line & sinker
being a clean comedian people came to me
like the fourth time last things said
you got a lot going on for you but you
gotta get that dirty stuff I'm gonna
make that [__] and I started thinking
about linger you're right
I said putting the suit on yeah right
off the bat by the time I was on stage
the eighth time I started wearing a suit
to a contest and I warned other suit and
then I won the contest I wore another
suit and then after that I had a credit
card from this one clothe here and I had
like $1,000 limit those suckers and I
went in there was [__] was it falling
apart and I just spent the whole thing
on suits and sniffing because I was
going down anyway so free year I wore
suits on stage if you play the game I
tried in Colorado and I a that bag of
dicks and then I took the same game to
New York City and I didn't do much
better you feel like people could could
see through it that it wasn't you yet I
tried really [__] hard
one night I was driving a limo and I
used to have a boxing there was a boxing
gym on like 48th and 8th up the corner
from Port Authority and I would pay the
guy like 20 [__] bucks to park for an
hour and a half and I would go upstairs
shower I had a little Locker up there
with hit the bag and do push-ups and
cents and jump rope and I will head to
pads with another guy for 20 bucks but I
could always take showers in the city
and go on a move from one night for a
t-shirt I didn't have a clean white
shirt I put a t-shirt on and I put a
leather jacket over and I won out of
stage and I just was going off about
what was going on in my life I tried
that Judy Carter approach talking about
what's bothering you were what kills you
and I went up there with that approach
and I destroyed that room that was one
of those points I was starting to think
about quittin ya didn't saying like oh
yeah no I mean I've gotten you start to
think about quitting well I got off a
bit I've had offers from like big record
label you know like clean it up and will
sign you or clean up and you can do this
show you could do that show and I've
just always been like then what it you
know the money's not that [__]
important you know it's like I'd much
rather do it my way and not you know
censor myself and you know that means
something to me to do it
you know be myself and do it but um but
you know don't get me wrong when I when
they offered like a big little label
offers me he hits me in the head like
you know maybe just clean up and try it
see you can get on the radio live you
know make that Billy Ray Cyrus money or
whatever it is but I just can't go I
just can't go through with it
it's a sacrifices you make to be
yourself because you know and I know one
little why's a little old you start to
learn that you saw you soul a little bit
and it sounds great at first but then
way into what you get into you started
losing in that ten years later you're
you know you're differ
person yeah I took a chance I knew right
away by the time I got back to Colorado
in 94 I was three years into economy I
knew what I wanted to do
[__] the suits yeah through guns back to
Who I am
you can't put other watts or all the
great you know performance come from
it's just like yeah [__] all this Shivan
didn't didn't trigger prior to that
spend the same thing yeah he wore suit
still towards the end I you just say my
world it was always you can't put a silk
hat on the pig I just always worried
that expression on my Jesus Christ I
know an expression when I was like 15
then they seven good froze ten years
later or something but you can't put a
silk count on a pig and I always knew
that for starters
one thing it did for me well that was
when I went to back from New York in 93
and I was an open mic ER I was walking
one day who I see walking bouge level
and I know hey Jan hey don't man
I'm a starting comic can you help me I
think it was just getting on stage
brother and I know you know what man
someday I'm gonna being on that show
would be the funniest Cuban you ever saw
and he goes I know a lot of funny Cubans
and he walked away from me for like a
year I had this fantasy going on Jay
Leno and doing a six minute clean set
and at one point I was like [__] gentle
gentle I could suck my dick [__] a lot
of big just suck my dick
everybody could suck my dick it's still
gonna need to be able that's all the
mess in my world at that time that's all
that really matters HBO once you hit HBO
they can all suck your dick they all
come running for you anyway so but
that's the decisions you make early on
that a lot of people come up to you know
maybe that's not even yeah when people
could do that all you know you can get
on [__] whatever it is now Fallon
call all that [__] like I can't I can't
understand what they're telling me I
have a chance because I sell records but
if I clean it up I could go do that ship
I'm just like what about they'd be but
they said they could they won't I guess
your networks don't
well they don't you know I like
10-second delay every case on this they
would they used to the old this they use
we were just talking about that time we
were told oh you were here you know
basis career really catapulted when he
got banned from sin
yeah I put that delay on yeah and he got
banned from MTV something about not
catastrophe is not a catastrophe what's
the word I'm looking for wheeler
controversy something about controversy
sells tickets when it comes from the
heart and it's real yeah because I'm not
trying to be controversial is you don't
know neither am i I'm gonna go up there
saying what I want to say and if we
don't want to Miami that's okay and I
made that decision up in 2001 well it's
a big decision is a big decision it's
like I'm gonna go down I'm gonna if you
my thing is what you probably yours is
to is like if I'm gonna fail I'm gonna
fail being myself I did I signed with
this big-time manager in like 97 and he
was good do you ever have a manager
that's better than you uh he was better
than me like he was getting me gigs and
I wasn't good enough or I wasn't he was
getting me into rooms Jack he was
getting me into movies like what met him
black he got me into menon but i think
he had me into it every huge director if
i call him up and go Jeff there's a
movie that's coming out he go he look at
me can I call you back
hey call me back you listen I just
picture the director man availeth
producer they want to see tape I told me
a little bit of a short film and stand
up I send him that and then one time he
took a video of me in Miami he was down
a whale of cruise and it was the
dirtiest set I had ever done hilarious
type shape when you're starting it no
like I'm broken the other day were you
talking about though like yeah that's
the [__] no let me just talk about the
guy with the ice in his mouth or
something else
all the [__] with I smile because device'
you know it's uh it's really [__] up
when you when you make that decision
that you're gonna work [__] Barry like
that said I'm done with well I don't
think I mean I don't think didn't tell
me if I'm wrong I don't think you made a
decision to work dirty just made a
decision to not censor yourself
are there other country artists that are
banned from places are you the only kind
of like I think I'm the only one yeah
that's pretty cool yeah I mean I've kind
of carved down my own lane at this point
which I kind of dig and uh and for
people who haven't heard I actually was
having lunch with someone yesterday who
works in the music industry and he said
he'll just leave loves listening to it
because it's really good music like it
was the thing is I said that was my goal
I said well at the time I had a kind of
a bigger manager I said he goes what do
you want to do I go I want to go in him
I want to make the greatest country I'm
of all time and make it completely
unplayable that was my goal
well he's like why the [__] is I was
like I don't know I just like [__] you
know just see if I can do it
so is it was I mean I literally just
made it for myself you know just like I
want to see how good I can be and how
much I can [__] myself over in the
industry you know and see if people will
still come and listen you know and it
worked you know so far it's been working
but you know at the end of the day a
good song is a good [__] so I mean we
were just watching Skynyrd I mean that
that [__] so good so it'll cut through
with anything it doesn't matter they
were saying [__] or [__] no matter what
doesn't get a [__] matter
they wouldn't even understand watching
that people out here yeah well they send
that to agents I feel this is a bright
new day they would go what the [__] is
that his brother that's the music I grew
up do you want to know why I'm [__] up
cuz I listen to that [__] with a hit of
acid in me I don't sing get a [__]
Jupiter when you're sad man special and
that other one the [__] walking up on
me like a cat all that creepy [__] you
take a hit of acid woman tens days gone
listen man when you [__] tripping and
come on what's the song he wrote for his
brother too good he's written two songs
that the opening lines have been
brilliant
what's the opening line it's a sound
that special I can't think about I can't
think of it right now
something about a [__] cat
and then look up the lyrics to I had two
feet they come on creeping like a black
cat do right alright that's the opening
lyric okay
listen to the opening lyric of that
smell whiskey bottle brand new car oak
tree in my way are you are you [__]
kidding me buy you a Hemingway can't do
that [__] no listen to that read the
first two lines of [__] uh that smell
yeah whiskey bottles and brand new cars
oak tree you're in my way the next one
there's too much coke and too much smoke
look what's going on and look what's
going on inside you the next wood Lee
Read's it's gonna eat oh that smell can
you smell that smell denim ooh that
smell
Danah the smell that's around you what's
up for what's the first track are you
[__] kidding me
you know what that does to you when
you're tripping a you're coked up cuz
now you start smelling your shirt you
think there is something surrounding
that I got a black diamond surrounding
me I'm saying I can't stop snorting
eatin [__] in order to take out pizza
this is terrible I haven't left the rule
of four days and don't want to what's
the first track on the first album that
one always gets me to the one that
freaked me out when Aaron was the first
real honest song out my boy was that the
Raceway where I used to get the Congress
[__] out of the dumpster from the
[__] whatever and it was gimme back my
bullets oh that's a killer when I took
that album home it blew my mind and then
I bought because of the cover there was
another country band that was not only
skin it feels how are you to death
somebody sent me an email or on day that
I was wrong there was two other bands
there one there one livid skin its radar
but they will not let it skin it no I
mean now that ship I have there was the
other three of them so with leather skin
it would have crossed once they once
they would have switched Ted Nugent
skidded
it was awful running after that yeah all
those bands there was eight bands there
was five that was solid that were
touring already and three little ones
that were gonna cross over with them and
then went away the cars two b-52s then
went away of all that music like Ozzy
Osbourne god knows what would have
happened with Ozzy's first time let the
skin it was about to take over yeah
those all those record dudes in New York
would have been probably flying out to
Florida Georgia looking for the next
Skynyrd and she instead of you know and
they did they tried this up my my
friends band I ain't the one I grew up
with a [__] dude Jesus Christ she was
very good to me growing up in fact I
spoke to him a couple times his sons in
a band they're from New Jersey and these
guys did like the other guy they did
like that did not the worst guy but the
guy in the lower scale NBC comes on that
one Oh Carson Dale arson Dale I just did
that show yeah hey ask me ask me what
Carson asked me what Carson Daly is like
what's he like don't know it didn't mean
him
hilarious yeah but uh he was on one of
those shows a band or something like
that but I watched him and they had a
little southern flavor to him I always
liked that son like you knows a good a
good southern rock band right now is
being called blackberry smoke you heard
yeah yeah that like the [__] solo
that [__] dickey betts does well I'd
said to you put it down so on that soil
destroys me how he took his [__]
neighborhood into those first couple
chords he just brought it you could
smell the barbecue he took you there oh
yeah I'm gonna check that out I get that
[__] all those concerts live
from the 70s a lot of them you're gonna
flip off after the third song these
Allman Brothers full concert you got an
hour to kill
download it next time you take a [__]
plane put it on with you those guys
lived lived all that it was all about
playing live back then you know nowadays
I mean is there any new band that you
give a [__] about seeing live no I would
but not for $657 brother exactly yeah I
thought it over and I gotta make a pass
on it
yeah you know yeah I got a family I got
mouths to feed and I could buy the CD
and jump up and down me and we could do
a hit ass and lock ourselves in there
turn out the lights and get extra
speakers I'd take this - they look how
he looks at me he's like please don't do
that to me
well they put on [__] Black Sabbath
to turn the lights down he goes [__] to
the watch did you see the Sabbath
reunion shows no I did not I saw him he
was good but it wasn't uh I mean you
know there's I saw the YouTube from this
last video now let's take everything
into consideration these guys are more
probably on their [__] 18th tour they
were all in this if these in the
seventies they're not even 40 and 50
like he won't make brother this 60 and
70 they performed every other night
twice a week watch Tony Iommi's get on
those YouTube page are you still going
yeah he's a [__] savage and Bill
Ward's the [__] Sabbath and how's the
I love I still don't know the mystery
whether he's singing with he's gotta
back then someone told me that he guys
that backstage sing in form but I told
you when I said when I saw him I said
he's got someone backstage I go if he's
got someone backstage sing for him like
I took the night off cuz he didn't hit
one note on key you 70-something music
yeah I'm a didn't bother me you can't
really drink and destroy your throat you
can't smoke you know they have like got
something that they could shoot I guess
I noticed dude - Stas user testosterone
doctor one of those age guys and there
someone's who comes here act as he was
my biggest market musician yeah all
these guys aren't tall that's what they
do to perform a little shot two times a
week of what testosterone yeah look what
does that do it makes you recover fast
okay okay you know and you ever see
ivory show Ozzy pours the bucket of
water over you know why he doesn't look
I know I hope I'm not telling these
stories out of school but this is what
was that
he's in cottony pissed his pants so um
they couldn't figure out what to do they
try to the diaper and all that [__] you
know Ozzy Osbourne can't go onstage and
a [__] diaper they're just in his
major just like you know watch us pour
water over your head you'll be soaking
wet no one can see a piss stain anyway
that's why he does it every show that's
crazy
cuz he's pissing himself you know what
just throw those tours in the seventies
and eighties and 60s well those guys
they lived 30 years every week like my
brother Bob Lowe Lingus sent me a book
about Jimmy Page three lives of Jimmy
Page I've been reading it for two months
I'm finally and put a dent in it but
right now with the last time I read it
was his last weekend this last weekend
it was about like one of their tours is
71 or something and it was just pure oh
yeah they should it's like they should
have been in cages yes they were [__]
animals they want animals like they just
it's it when you're reading it you're
shaking your head baby how they live how
about like the question is how to have
bottom even lived that long when you
read those hooks bottom Keith Moon Eric
Clapton first of all clap then those
guys will heart on [__] heroin deep
page I'm [__] Dean dumb right showed
us one time networks again 79 you ever
see that no Led Zeppelin's doing the
kill these last night after the show
we'll put it on for you Jimmy Page is
being held up by the bones and his
[__] shoulders he's down 80 pounds
brother the heroin had him to opt-in
beep he was on Harold oh no
he went back to Alex to Crowley's cake I
was gonna say yeah I didn't sat in there
for three [__] he lived and raping
that woman and [__] you know here's
of an Alistair college place living with
a little girl yeah he was up there
[__] doing the evil things I ain't
mad at mrs. Barry business
yeah people lived how they lived in
those days makes sense all ours looked
pretty taste told your animals on tour
but I read an interesting story from
Keith Richards book about the chick the
blind chick who used to come to all the
shows and Keith Richards find out she
was blind so you pay them the guys that
carried the stagehands to take him from
spot to spot and take the camera when he
got busted for heroin the little blind
girl found out and she hitchhiked to
Canada and found out what the judge was
knocked on his door and explain to him
who Keith Richards really was the type
of person he was that he looked after on
the road when she was just a runaway and
she wanted to follow the band he didn't
never tried the [__] made sure nobody
[__] her and [__] Allah and the
judge took the case in to consider you
know he took the burn yeah man yeah I
thought that was like they're savages
tit listen we all know what we bump into
when I bumped into over the years I know
the people I bump into now are a lot
better than people
I was bumping into 15 years ago of the
road I mean there was nights I couldn't
get a hold of my deal on the farm in
town
and I got a monkey on my back it's for
no more than I got a chick on the couch
well I just got ready to [__] take
off her panties and we realize we're
down to a grandma blonde this thing of
her I gotta stick some in her [__]
and suck it out you know I gotta do evil
things that 6:00 in the morning
daylight's coming and yeah I'd do some
evil things in the middle night bro
knock on doors it's horrible so you were
pretty or you were pretty at your worst
was pretty bad yeah I was going to eat
more than one Oh what do you think huh
sorry if I'm not being too personal but
like what was the worst geez you think
just like could you was so how was it
how hard was it to quit it was a
decision yeah it was a decision based on
a promise based on who I've become
it took me about a year to really quit
but at that time I really liked the road
oh my god like I was going nuts when I
do you just kind of weekends and stuff
yeah but I would still do weekends back
then but I would plan them like let's
say I had to work Wednesday Thursday
Friday sadly I'd fly down there Tuesday
night at 5:00 I get to your town and I
realize had enough plans I had enough
cash for two packs of cigarettes the
coke I was gonna buy but if I did a show
that night I get a draw so I could show
up in your town flat broke that night
for Dylan just has two hallways booking
you back then just use the book of
myself but I was getting [__] like I'm
ever gonna Houston being there for two
weeks and snorting every night except
what huh like every night except one
like snort until somebody still to some
that's a gone one package is pretty good
but one night the coke was good forget
about it I'd snap Tony in the morning
talking [__] drawing pictures whacking
off smoking cigarettes drinking a little
alcohol act like a [__] [__] at
the end what's so fun about that he
doesn't sound fine no that was the last
three years but every once in a while if
I picked up a freak that I trusted or
somebody who was cool with me here I'm
telling him you're really really cool
with me and I know me and we're gonna
lock ourselves in for six hours and and
talk some [__] and maybe get two [__]
broads to come over and [__] stick
[__] put some way to walk of music on
eat their [__] right next to each
other you know say well the good old
days man it's brought some Tony Bennett
brother
it's Monday
you
but we think my fingers are greasy
telling what she said chuckling tomorrow
you should walk huh my little brother
Lee how funny is that [__] and you
know what it's something I cut it out
there and pull it out that I know
Lee's ashamed you know he feels guilty
believe there's nothing to be guilty
about we saw it look at the for anybody
I love what leaf nobody's gonna say that
you're everyone what are you talking
about this is a director right now I was
looking for a chubby little Jew to be a
neurotic David [__] it whatever you
say I just gave you an offer do that on
stage some [__] fun annual you intend
drinking you have no idea how funny you
enjoy your highest [__] with you falling
apart and you will keep it together and
that's the soldiery most people would
have thrown the headphones down push the
[__] you would have picked up graybow
or whatever rien whatever his name is
you were bossy oh my little brother you
would have picked him up throwing him
out the door head first
he was bang this off the American flag
and then you were to just kick Dean's
door a run against the Victrola over
here the little engine that was
established it would come to me and then
you look at me you know I'm your brother
so you jump over the table and the way I
you'd step on that poor kid kick him in
the mouth and you'd run out of here and
run down the street call 9-1-1 and go
with her Fire Department and they'd
probably put you in a wet suit those
suits that they wrap you around and they
take it for the psychiatric thing
because they find blowing the issue mean
why I take this other kid to a [__]
Hospital and I got buried deep down
right here it's a nod and go shovel and
drop Dean's dowry off off the 170 with a
Rolling Stone poster in his hand know
how he would both they can't blame it on
the [__] Hollywood ball himself and
then like my car on fire and reported
[__] stolen after his charcoal to
death off the [__] 101 north
somewhere that would be my evening
so please do me no favors exam I see
that [__] I [__] I love it but
nothing like an embarrassing way I'm
just like that's a champ most
people will crack under pressure yeah I
wanted I was just looking at that door
in that condition and knowing that that
door is closed and there's three people
in front of you to get out and you're
not gonna get out in time you're gonna
have a nervous breakdown
all right I've been in situation Wirefly
and I have to a little doctor [__]
xanaxes and they're in that bag scotch
tape they don't move I never touch them
but because there's a couple times I
want on planes and I got it let's just
hang out a little bit too [__] high
on edibles and I thought about opening
up that [__] window and jump it out
and I'll tell you it's not good oh no I
don't fly without for you I don't fly
without Z&X with me listen to me bro
Sunday I had was how I adventures again
wait you ready
again again this can only happen to you
uncle Joey
I get the [__] wherever I was last
week which I had a great time Omaha
Omaha Nebraska and I get to the [__]
doubt the terminal early I you breakfast
like a gentleman
and I'm right that terminal c4 I'm
sitting down against the wall minding my
own business ready to get in the [__]
line to board the plant and a black nice
[__] cold dude comes up to me go see
do I know you from somewhere like on
that I don't think so he I do I bet you
from some movies and [__] you know and I
said yeah I think my name is whatever he
was a gentleman we start talking and
stuff he knows we live in LA I hate you
whatever New York type of guy on that I
live in LA and I know he goes you like
it I go there I'm having my issues you
know I think I've been there for too
long I'm ready to move on you know he
goes what don't you like about and I go
well for starters look around the
[__] terminals
look at Terminal one look at Terminal
[__] - what do you see I go look over
there you see real people's look at this
terminal
cattle company if all these people
hadn't heard of cap you what do you call
those those skull caps you know
everybody has a skull cap on because the
airports
[__] miserable freezing place there
was a guy with pink shoes and in the
front in a row waiting to get on
everybody had a weird hairdo there's a
chick with a t-shirt barely covering her
tits belly button out tight pants shoes
there's the chick with the purse with
the little chihuahua in it oh it's it's
it's endless it's endless the parade of
jerk-offs whatever Airport you go to him
you get on the flight to LA it's endless
I mentioned this to the guy and I
mention this the guy I go wow how many
service dogs we go he goes always just
got that girl with the dog in her basket
in her [__] purse I know he does
you're right
there's always service dogs don't be
people with three service dogs one
person three service dogs and an
assistant that's [__] yeah I mean I
have my [__] hey listen I get on the
plane you know me guys I'm always one
see that's just a way of this when I get
on a plane I don't [__] around
I want one see if I don't have it we buy
it we figure how to get one see or one
[__] B and then we moved back with one
by one and then once I get to the
airport we try to deal with if I got one
seat going there and coming back I sit I
put my [__] on top I take my headphones
off I take my Walkman let put my wall in
the back cuz I don't need it and I put
my little cell phone with me with my
glasses I got my little nicotine gum I
ain't bothering nobody
some [__] Harvey homo with his
assistant comes up to move his breathing
back and he goes you're in my [__]
chair
that's on my day starts at [__] 5:25
in the morning I'm [__] Sunday I
haven't bothered anybody I haven't even
said bullying they blame self with his
little black gentlemen and this cab
driver tried to give me any a beatin
about his son and Iberia jumping up and
down taking pictures of polar bears what
are you telling me for five years one
I'm barely up I did ten shots of coffee
and something to lick my ass out and get
me up and you're bothering me about your
kids hunting taking pictures of all the
Bears of
Berrien for [__] thing the more than
you [__]
I love you know so I said 10 think Isaac
asked my channel no I'm one say he looks
at me as no I'm one see I go listen I'm
1z I just look at the ticket I'm on this
row pop I'll I go I'm one see he looks
at me goes why I gotta get to the bottom
is cuz that's my chair that's why I
always sit oh my god that's why I always
said so he laughed as his assistant
stayed there glaring at me like he was
gonna do some piece yeah
so I leveled my foot sideways so if he
came to me I can stop him in his knees
and get up and with one foot and just
punch him in the [__] throat and end
it right there for me give me ten years
in the [__] federal prison up in
Lompoc about how ride horses and Leo
come up once a week and with the podcast
live from the prison good song for
reactivation into the [__] land you
follow me is that what la is for you now
so what happened so he came back and he
goes that's my tango none one see and
the guy goes will show him is tickin the
guy was [__] 4c and he goes who no it
doesn't matter I want to sit down are
you [__] serious
I'll go on the back get in the dungeon
and in this little [__] party let me
tell you what happened towards it was a
crazy flight even the [__] attendants
pass on it this flight was crazy
something else happened in the flight it
was they they attend dungeon the two
first class attendance were black and
there was a guy on there that would open
up the top pull this [__] out his shirt
before to help me go back in this corner
sit this happened about four or five
times and lady said something and he
knows really think I played for
first-class for you pick it up
that was like rudeness right there and
then with ten seconds ten minutes ago on
the flight to do or I told me getting
the dungeon his lover
walks past me and goes in the bathroom
I'm watching [__] I tried to watch
playing games again the most racist they
have a song
watch I saw the movies I had to walk
down and abandon you
yes it did offend me for the first time
I grew up on pilings Houston where was
my favorite movies of all time beneath
the Planet of the Apes when they amassed
themselves under the Lincoln Tunnel in
the home tunnel the greatest scenes ever
and [__] him to the media but it changed
my outlook when I saw this now it's real
racist when I was a kid it was like my
racist and I got high and he knows let's
black people we can't do that
his assistants like we can't do that
well what can we sub sit - that's up to
- an ape some monkeys that's what they
did I honestly believe that I think yeah
I think that and as I get older now that
I saw this one they really went crazy
titania you don't meet dog I'm half
racist I'm not racist but I say racist
[__] and well I like a new play of the
movies but you're gonna ruin for me yeah
I'm windy knob old school I grew up and
I come from Cuba cinemas big for me and
guy like me I sit there I watch all
those when I came I'd never forget my
friends telling me you gotta go see
beneath the Planet of the Apes
you know like 15 I was obscene well see
what it looks like break up Riley if
she's [__] a hole seriously put on
bait the pile of the Apes peel skin
scene watch this this is gonna [__]
creep you out there's the type of [__] I
went to just given the face skins scene
pull it up on the computer my brother
big-screen there's my uncle joy William
yes nice why you playing games with me
Lana's gonna YouTube
Jesus I see your time on the plane the
new ones no the old one you were
watching all ones no I was watching the
[__] new ones no one day I went to
the movie theater and I tried to watch
the no one that was gone for a while and
as I'm watching him go away saying they
created this in the 70s they create this
in the 60s this was Planet of the Apes
then beneath the Planet of the Apes then
escape from the Planet of the Apes then
revenge or plan of the Apes well that
was a kid that was like four or five of
them
American blockbusters but they were
interesting films but beneath the Planet
of the Apes have a scene where I had to
be six or seven guys okay let me see
fountains seen from beneath the players
let's see that scene
did you put it and that no it's called
planets 1968 so guys when this move face
peel see she's right there that's for
the first one made the player here try
that one there what the [__] that's the
missile that's when I shoot kill the
world and the Apes have if somebody's
got this [__] thing telling the
surface to Puerto Ricans
you know the [__] note it's a scary
[__] scene when you're a child like I
said I was [__] five and my friends
talked me into going to see this some
hug for mady 8th Street I went like I
[__] we just scared of going to zoos
after that like what you're scared of
actual Apes yeah I went to the Bronx Zoo
a couple days after that it's a
three-day excursion in those days
walking around the [__] Bronx Zoo but
no it was uh I don't know I just taped
it off and I watch the show I was
watching Jay Jay well I gotta go I need
a new show to watch show trial no
because it's the Spanish you don't watch
the knuckles yet I'll walk you out
what's not you know I don't know Netflix
has some great [__] you got a hunted
that's a good thing about Netflix if you
got time you'll find something you know
old TV series like I recently watched
cheers and Fraser I'm gonna go to the
gym that's what I do
yeah that's like comfort food it's like
makes me feel good yeah I just want
something on in the background yeah
someone's telling me
well someone talked about today is that
ozark everytime no that's not familiar
oh yeah I've heard about that I haven't
seen that one that's the one about the
money launderers I haven't heard any
Mozart I some about money laundering or
something like that
I've been we were watching a Kirby
enthusiasm lurking catch up and watch
the news you didn't watch it once before
our spots pocket to the point we just
the hook though I've seen that one
obvious things when I first watched that
one now what happened Saturday night did
you watch it yes yes I'd live yes what
was it offensive to you oh no I'm sorry
are they talking about the UFC no I did
not watch that no no I heard about it
what was it what was the thing something
about Hitler or someone I think what the
Holocaust was a pick-up line be at
Auschwitz hey how's it going you know
[__] like that which like you can my
wife and I were talking about this
I don't know guys I was raised under the
thing me that way kya that means [__] is
boom boom whoa right but number two was
fix and stones don't break my bones yeah
and words will never help me and
whatever they hurt me call me this call
me that I still say you're a big fat rat
whatever you say sticks to you well I'm
rubber you're good I'm rubber you're
glue so that's what you were raised as
all of a sudden now we've sensitized
everything bro yeah it's a weird time to
be doing over Ito a [__] somebody's
apologizing what I had a question what
do you think that is cuz you know we got
the you know the dirtiest president ever
so true think it would open [__] up more
no no no no it's tightening the
liberalism is tightening bro they took
Columbus Day away because he killed
people 3000 years ago what the [__] do
we know I mean [__] the wheel at this
point shouldn't be able to say [__]
[__] on NBC I don't understand no listen
man that's their big but listen that
sponsorship money
that's all I'm BC this is going down
yeah it's NBC's decision FX is that fact
for a reason Fox said you know what we
don't want to show that [__] but what if
we create a neighborhood cable network
that the rules are a little lighter and
you can say [__] and [__] and
everything except this word told 10
o'clock at night
did you hear Disney's gonna buy that
well trying to buy that what FX like
they're splitting up a bunch of the Fox
products
I love FX I love what they've done I
love the chances they take and everybody
gets to watch and you make a decision
[__] yeah and they got sponsors on
there so I don't want to [__] hear it
you know sons of anarchy did tremendous
numbers that crime should that late
Horror Show
the spooky show oh yeah American Horrors
really [__] brilliant every season is
[__] brilliant
I like that better than anything I want
the last couple of [__] years I don't
mind spooky [__] that's got action to it
I don't listen I'm 50 [__] 4 if
you're gonna jump out of the thing with
a glove and a mask on
just coming by money back just get my
money back it's 2017 I see in [__]
the first [__] whatever I like that
[__] as a kid I saw the exercises again
I like that [__] the Exorcist to me is
the scariest movie ever watch because it
scares you when you go home it'll affect
you for the first two weeks put the
light on if you hear a rat your house
Rosemary's Baby - yes baby all those
type of movies psychologic but they were
smart yeah then there's the movies that
make you yelling you see I don't like
that I don't like that that's high blood
pressure [__] that's just like easy to
do just quiet and then like yeah you
know it's coming but you still get
scared ya know the people next to act
like [__] Momo's but you're already
too high you might as well stay in there
what the [__] I don't know I like
certain type of horror I like Alfred
Hitchcock I like [__] Shining The
Shining
I enjoy what's that [__] the other
one The Twilight Zone
yeah that could be [__] spooky as
[__] because you have a child I was a
kid it was the last show on but I grew
up on honeymooner odd couple Sanford and
Son Twilight Zone 12:30 Twilight so are
you [__] get why so I was pretty head
of a Twilight Zone is still they do
Twilight Zone marathon next time
Thanksgiving comes around and sci-fi
doesn't whatever I want you to make sure
you tape the one with burgess Meredith
when he wears glasses at the end of the
world happens I want you to take the one
with Sebastian Cabot where he plays the
devil in a white suit it's [__]
brilliant
the writing will take you from one
dimension to another and there's a cup
there's like five more that you can't
think of off the top of your head that
when you walk because I've seen all as a
kid I was that was the only show that
when I was a kid they had already
seasons of it already and they were kind
of weird they were kind of blackout even
or black and white through these ones so
you didn't want to watch them I even
went back and watch them and I've always
enjoyed them there's something I don't
want to see you again yeah I'll watch
those marathons I love that it's like I
love TV that's like movies whatever
that's smarter than me that's a step
ahead of me you know nowadays I can just
guess what's happening I know what's
happening that next scene no matter what
like I said this thing that I got turned
into let me tell you why I'm like
Spanish TV because it reminds me of
being a child and watching telenovelas
and I got taste on this production
company whoever they are in my eyes
they've hit it out of the park because
they're three for three it's three for
three then North Coast this show and
celeea about a Cuban all about Celia
Cruz to Cuba check another 88 [__]
episodes ha ha I think they got it down
to a science it's a mix of film and tell
them apart again
they got interesting characters they got
a [__] character the name Omega okay
this is this is about a prison this is
about a hit man that killed 250 people
and responsible for 3,000 people he
pulled the trigger in one way or the
other but before he turns himself in
while they hunt in Pablo he cuts a deal
for seven years and they put him in a
Capitol prison and it's run by track bug
traffickers as their own would sell
paramilitary and then the guerrillas the
commies and all his [__] so it takes you
deep he goes in there and he's one step
behind everybody he's like a [__]
Spanish the guy from the sons identity
whatever he does he's always got
coverage he tells he takes these tales
that he does like one thing he did was
he started writing he found the
publisher offered him money and he
started writing this a true [__]
story bro he started writing and he got
the publisher to come in to give him an
offer and to bring the machines into the
prison
so his co-workers in the prison could
have worked and they could earn money as
a read whatever at the society program
what didn't know it was that this guy
wrote this book but he was putting acid
in the paperwork in the books and
shipping him out and they would call
like Barnes & Noble you would walk in
there let me get all the books for
[__] what's-his-name but you would
take him back to a lab and they cut the
sheets out
he took cocaine he took cocaine out of
Colombia replaced it with acid and he
did it all from this prison it was crazy
what did he get there he got a chemist
in there and they got everything
smuggled in it's Colombia if you have
money you live like a diamond they are
presenting the books in there that's why
yeah that's why they they fought
extradition
because down there with a million
dollars you go to jail but it's like
being home you got a bed you got a
big-screen TV and guess what if you have
that type of money you got twenty
one-year-old freaks coming in every
night you go can they oh yeah
they have [__] in there every night
you paint a guard draw they come in at
midnight
hotter than [__] but then you gotta have
a million dollars to do that like those
narcotraffic kind things and fifteen
million American dollars in the bank
when they went to prison yeah my turn
fifteen billion dollars in the bank from
selling coke how would you live in
prison not in the United States not
anymore
you might find a couple [__] crooked
guys I'll let you do something but I
doubt it's gonna be like high-level like
you don't live in Colombia
look how Pablo Escobar built the inside
of that place and talk Colombians the
[__] important himself in there did you
ever stop and think about that I lived
through that I remember reading about
that going is it me or is this [__]
just crazy and it was just a lot of
builders own present yeah and then that
you knew he was building soccer fields
in there and who tunneled who tunneled
out Oh chop oh well chop he's in New
York Inman and
you're in prison he's a brother on trial
so they have mid New York yeah cuz he
escaped
New Mexico linking the kyndra's Mexico
let me give some shoutouts real quick -
my little brother Andrew McCartan my man
young health time kooky spooky my girl
passenger shaming get over Cairo Taiwan
can deep Jeffrey Collins as usual Nikki
shades and regular car reviews don't
forget I think the link is up next
Tuesday I'm doing this showcase you
[__] torture thank you you guys
torture Netflix thank you I'm getting
Netflix [__] showcase next Tuesday 8
p.m. Comedy Store and then the following
Wednesday Irvine improv the night before
Thanksgiving he's making an appearance
he loves the hamburgers down there you
know how are we doing those have been
the best rides of our lives the first
ride I took down there with League I was
10 minutes away from pulling over and
telling me the [__] take over the
wheel make a u-turn and go home we got
so high by mistake one time the first
time it was on purpose no purpose ok
everything is well planned out but
sometimes plans backfire I've talked
about a thousand times sometimes the
edible turns on you which was time with
this hello listen I got video of it let
me explain something did edibles trailer
you from time to time you met him more
from bad feeling you've been thinking
about son maybe you watch like Ostrom of
the episodes and next thing you know you
know the motive turns on you and it
backfires on your body DNA is off maybe
a lot of cheese that day maybe I'm no
testosterone in your system and next
thing you know you sit on the cat's
thinking about [__] shoot yourself
but you want to watch [__] your
friends on Jimmy Kimmel and that's
what's keeping you alive I mean you get
so [__] high sometimes but sometimes
you can show it here on the church we
take chances why because that's how you
got a row what if you bump into somebody
they give you someone the street on the
up-and-up
and they would joke guess what happens
we're prepared
if you dosed me with a pot cookie
nothin's gonna happen
Oh Miami Molly or Molly Molly the [__]
are we talking about here you know I
don't know I love it it's just like I
know we always [__] good people yes
that's why I love it here it's like use
its own dimension you know no this is
listen from the beginning from day one I
wanted people to hear something learn
something and take some home with them
you know family I really want them to
have that feeling of there's no
pretentious to say this is who I am
this ain't no [__] yeah I'm not doing
this for my help I really enjoyed doing
this and talking to people who were
young who were [__] having problems
you know last week somebody posted on
the wall that there were 23 and you know
and it takes me back like how [__]
[__] up was I had 23 how scared was I
was just scared
well what was this guy saying then he
was 23 and he was going through a hard
time I really am really [__] with me
because I remember everybody thinks it
just happens you know in this life I
love how people's attitude is that this
just happens no this this happens
because of discipline and even though we
want to do something we don't do it
that's when you really grow as a
musician as a comedian that's a
different yeah I mean the whole thing
that with me was I don't think I would
have gotten this if it wasn't for the
2,000 people who told me I can't do it
that was a whole point I gotta prove to
you that you know what I don't I don't
need the [__] radio
I don't need [__] Jimmy Fallon on you
know that [__] [__]
I'll sell I'll sell tickets anyway I'll
figure you know we'll figure it out you
know like I said the good thing about
you is I go watch you I know I'm real
good I'm gonna watch
good [__] musicians great composed
music the lyrics about this fat chick
sucking your pipe that's the cherry on
me it's just like if you really like
country music
do you have no excuses here you just
can't you can't take the words come on
how old that's my thing - it's just like
it
trying to do is I mean me I'm turned to
a million things but one of us is Jill
country Riza used to be fun that was the
whole point like let's take this
traditional country music with great
musicians and sing about dick-sucking
and you know let me tell you something
if you don't think I'm I hope you don't
think I'm blind even though I want to
see Kenny Rogers in 83 and I want to see
somebody else in the country realm that
Kris Kristofferson I think I went to see
Willie Nelson with them my buddy Jimmy V
yeah Willie Nelson still got it but I
also saw some I saw the corporation come
into country music oh yeah now saw them
take the they took a rock mode they
turned it into like when they were hot
on the five kids singing and dancing
together
New Kids on the Block it's on your block
and the other ones and the other one
well that's the war I've got all those
guys [__] pissed on me cuz it's like
this is not it's it's it's it's
corporate pop control group on country
it's not country music it's well [__]
produced yeah but something you know I
know who really has the country in their
heart and I know who's freaking the [__]
yeah people see through it it takes it
takes it takes it takes ten seconds
seconds doesn't listen to it they
realize what the [__] is you know but
it's really weird how it's become so
country music is just a Country Music
Awards is you know it's [__] honey
when you sit down no what the [__] is
this you want to hear something crazy
so the Country Music Awards the biz the
big awards show and I have a duet on
this on the new record Oh wheeler called
[__] around a friend of mine is on
the CMA Board in he em he wrote the song
[__] around with me and uh he was at a
CMA meeting you know the last ballot
before the nominees the head of this
Country Music Awards goes we got a
problem here and you go in there
everyone's like was there's a song by
the some guy named Willy Walker jr.
called [__] around it's still on the
ballot and the final ballots tomorrow
like what do we do that mean is he might
know what the [__] this is and my
friends like yeah I co-wrote the song I
wrote it was with wheeler and he goes
and they're like um you know
what do we do I mean what do we do if it
gets a nomination they had to decide the
meeting that will put the asterisks in
or whatever so I was this close to it
okay I don't want it because I don't
want to have to go to that [__] but
how cool would it be you gotta go no it
would have been people you wouldn't the
duel what the [__] do you believe it
yeah you got it it would have been a
nice [__] the other short to see though
up and tell him all this sucks but yeah
I was thought was this close to a vocal
event of the year was the category good
for you but which a you know it doesn't
clearly count cuz no one knows about it
that's why I'd say on the church that
feels good that the fans had your [__]
back on this well if it felt it was
weird cause it's not fans it was the
it's industry voting on how crazy is it
I don't know how it got that far because
the music is [__] ferment I think
people if you really like that music and
you don't mind some Larry's like I said
what the [__] is wrong with you you go
out to eat ass and eat [__] nobody goes
out to leave the gig and go to church
nobody not one person everybody takes
one of those hot chunky little country
blondes she's been a fan I don't say all
those all those clean country guys are
just doing blow and [__] girls you
know can they do steroids these guys
need to I always say they need to stop
going to the gym and take some guitar
lessons you know things take some
singing lessons but yeah me it's just
it's just a bunch of [__] and I'm
sick of it and I'm it's I took a nice
big [__] you to all them you know but
it's working see that's the if you were
sitting here like not touring and not
selling tickets and not having the
success you're having then I go listen
you you took a chance Columbus did go
home regroup get those [__] lyrics
pin it well I thought I was political is
x-ray the [__] words on them now go
back with this great music you have and
listen let me tell you what the beauty
about this is how many what numbers this
is out number two yeah you don't do two
more at least probably yeah and then you
know indoor realm with no dirty lyrics
you think so oh yeah you're gonna get do
it for your brilliant you're gonna get
your the right shows and
and I want you to picture who you want
to write these songs with and I
guarantee if you write 10 good souls are
you were right
you only have two of those hot crunchy
tips assigned to work with you you've
got a great voice that leaves a decide
and [__] with them you already won the
war now you really want to come on their
face let me show you what the fool of
[__] I'm wrong with yeah I'll do a
10-city tour and call it the suck my
dick tour and yeah you do what's the
song on the radio suck my dick Toria I
said now you switch them this is
longevity this is Madonna type [__] what
would Madonna do why did McDonald last
20 years because she was [__] around
she was [__] with the ad guy look at
her history next time you got it next
time you're a problem making money find
someone by Madonna and yes she sucked a
little dick you see her complaining
about Harvey Weinstein come no I'm
saying but Donna blue Harvey Weinstein
15 times you ever see a complaint she
joined your yoga she [__] twisted
until the mid bad minerals came out of
those those little [__] Jew little
sperm
pedophile Jews these are the little
dungeon Jews that's a lie column
I guess I guess my profiles worse than
done no he's one of those dungeon Jews
oh these [__] Madame [__] you is
least not one is let me tell you
something they haven't even discovered
half of what Weinstein has oh can you
imagine oh my god I read an article
today that he have a hired like private
investigators I'm like a team I'm still
left over the Dougs you
I followed he keeps little girls in the
basement at some little dungeon Jew in
Israel and they keep he keeps like a
little Frieda like they do for your cat
when you leave for a year it's like a
little FINA with Cheerios
hand sanitizer he flies into Israel he
climbs into the hole he [__] the [__]
having a dungeon
he throws some Jewish laws of the land
yeah he flies back to America he's gotta
have [__] and safes that would [__]
destroy people because he's creepy so if
he did it for this long that means he
got confidence and he taped a few no oh
you have to think like him right now I
think come on with it unless you don't
unless you're that [__] dumb he's
listen he's a whole dungeon jewel number
one he's got a vase at all he's gonna
come out of there with something there's
some place there's a apartment where he
took girls he rented hotels okay but he
couldn't have been that stupid because
up to get 24 Seasons Hotel this campus
so he couldn't be that [__] stupid so
after a while when they got happened
through the investigations again and
he's got about five or six got some
Pablo Escobar pads all over Beverly
Hills Palm Springs San Diego maybe Santa
Barbara where he would drive and make
the girls go up then drive to get away
you gotta hardly to bang these girls you
gotta get away through the paparazzi and
he ain't stupid he was doing it for that
long white woman who said he molested
them 20 years ago correct yo so someone
should take him to trial now for some
reason to take him to trial and he you
know I don't know how low it's gonna
happen there he's got three
investigations guys
he said they any if anything different
they connect all this he's gonna die in
jail cuz he's gonna get 40 years he's
gonna get 10 he's gonna get 15 years can
carat from three different [__]
spades they're gonna [__] take him to
they're gonna find him in California and
find them in New Yor
then what was the do England I know he's
broke I know he's cleaned up but again
he's a dungeon Jew
he's got three mil and [__] pesos and
the mill and Google ransomware
but at the same time he's got to have
films on somebody he's a creepy I'll go
with the felony though the film he would
sell it to [__] penthouse of the
highs better you gotta be kidding me
can you imagine what a film of of him
naked if you think [__] what's other
guy what's the popular guy play the
harmonic on the podcast who played the
harmonica on the podcast and freaky huh
ron jeremy ron jeremy
oh he kept one of my shape you think ron
jeremy [__] up naked now did you
imagine [__] how he wants to make it
would angelina jolie's sucking that
flute oh and him telling I'm gonna give
you three movies suck it hard that she's
looking those balls and [__] and you
imagine something like that surfaces so
he's got to have some ace in the hole
he's he's just never thought about like
he's not in [__] Arizona rehab he's
sitting around with three high-powered
[__] Jews trying to figure out what
his strategy is gonna be he's just
sitting tight right now I wouldn't be
surprised if Harvey Weinstein hasn't
already got a [__] plane ready to
drill here's Mike where's the honest
question maybe you guys can answer like
obviously he's just sick [__] and I'd
I'm not I'm against what he's doing in
case they take this clip out but if you
tell a girl to suck your dick to be in a
movie is and they do it is is that a
leak what's I don't know I'm saying like
in that of a gray area it's a gray area
because white take the acting lessons
yeah saved $8,000 in the school of
dancing you never need to play the piano
obviously it's not cool but like what's
the what's the loss and I want to know
the percentage rate he was running that
how many chicks did suck him to take if
he molested sixty of them how many
chicks did suck his dick and who suck
this is what you on the other side of
the coin that's gonna people speculate
about and you know this is gonna get
interesting but let's say a lot
then drops the charges and New York
picks it up for rape and somebody else
these are all people saying this
happened 30 years a lot of the wall
works on all the statute of limitations
I don't know what you're gonna use for
fingerprints or the sample from your
vagina the underwear this leftover semen
from the ejaculation well I don't know I
just want Special Victims Unit like
everybody else
yeah that's it it's it's but right now
he's not getting help he's talking to
talk about ten minutes a day these are
there with a saw he's the herring and
[__] and my house what that's what got
him [__] up that he's an arrogant [__]
okay yeah she saw me give her three
months I was shut the [__] up sign the
contract that dumb [__]
and then what everybody leaves he tells
his assistant I had a son I put in her
ass like four [__] times she loved it
he's one of those guys you could tell by
looking at him oh yeah I mean the type I
haven't liked he didn't want to work on
his personality and I'll actually pick
him up he had women that would suck his
dick whenever they see him even if they
were involved in a relationship even if
they're involved in relationship they
bump into a party they go there with
their husband so tell me how's it excuse
me how he's going to show me a new kind
of his new movie in his studio keep
talking to leat I'll be right back two
minutes then go and then they swallow
the sword they come up with that come
breath and the next thing you know they
got three packets dealers [__] you know
you gotta think about what happened then
so he's a creepy [__] man but right
now he's not getting help
yeah it sounded like from the article
they just like would take it out it
didn't sound like he was offering it
like if you would do this Oh kindly yeah
didn't tell me was to post let's say
I've said let's say there's the type of
dude I read this one thing he herring on
the movie set from the so called actor
the actor dated this actress for a while
and they broke up and I guess after the
thing wrapped they went to a hotel and
they would drink out at the bar and the
the started describing his relationship
with this chick and how good their sex
life was and you know think about if I
tell you how hot this chick is how good
of a dick she sucks in your present the
next time you see under your presidents
to do whatever why are we suddenly if I
look like Brad Pitt I can walk around my
dick out all day cuz i know chicks for
bound speak into the microphone as i
walk past their house you don't say you
walked out of a but you get 18 [__]
and three chicks fainted and passed off
meet exhaustion beautiful [__] yeah
you're Brad Pitt you know in my mind
Brad Pitt to walk down the street with
his dick out and nobody about 9-1-1
toby reports that there was a penis
hanging out of his pants oh by the time
he hears the sirens were put in and it
was just a shadow of the Sun you know
it's [__] up but it's true brother
that's definitely too I mean you're out
there doing shows you really have to
watch yourself you know I I did I do
I did my record today you know it we
were both talking about touring and
stuff and I know the difference about
how I was living ten years ago how I
would sleep two hours in two days and
then get on a [__] plane first thing
in the morning and it would be like me
on the [__] twilight zone Lee being
the [__] Twilight Zone I was just
walking around then it'll get to LAX and
take a cab and I probably made 1,200
bucks
I spent 600 I'll blow you know I spent
the hundred on food a halogen on the
hotel room a hundred on the cab ride now
I'm coming home with three loves to see
my [__] girlfriend she's expecting
1,200 I got a mere 300 it's tough I used
to go on the road just to go [__]
bananas now I go on the road to write
and read any two good meals and you come
along with Muslim money I come home with
all the money I don't even take an
advance I'll even think you know I don't
even think about it
I take him I hit deposit when I leave
lax cash deposit or withdraw 200 bucks
and then my ATM card for the big things
that I'll tell you leave your card and
if you want to eat son
you pull on your room nobody [__]
gets their feelings hurt
and that your receipts and I stapled my
receipts they're gonna hand them to my
wife Sunday night and she does all the
accounting I'm here we are talking to
each other nobody's going to jail that's
the way I don't be the back of my door
tell me at the IRS I owe me this
I'm too old to do federal time like that
I got that type of [__] cash to have
were you going up there dropping off
envelopes and playing checkers with me
things get bad had a pimply in there
behind the walls of debt and Lompoc so
much wanna tell them oh would you the
stories why am i in there now because
you're my dog you'll take a bullet for
you uncle Joey you know I'm not running
prison he's gone and you're going with
no I'm not taking in there but you're
coming once a week I have a guy you rub
his balls and sing him a song and teach
him how to podcast and gives you the
small 300 and you throw a [__] where is
he eating at 300 because beau forgot
like you I get 500 promised him you
[__] then wave them over the head
with a stick what the feel is balls yeah
got a [__] yes on the man's lap
jiggle is balls Gina if you look fully
like undressed any like you like you
Santa and they don't tell you how cute
you want to rub your head I'll probably
get you on the lips once or twice office
well again this actually sounds like fun
man then you'll rub his little nuts
through his jeans until you can't take
it no more stick your hand down his
pants and I'll be like 400 bills you
pull it out you kiss me on the cheek you
tell me you love it let him rub your
head he'll try to touch your dick you
hear this hand you found that needs more
money and that the car you if he wants
to see you again and then next time
you're were dressed with small 752 I'm
saying like will work and will even
welcome students going real well
so what post your loan payments are oh I
have the student loans payment in
[__] three weeks I've got so much I
get three little [__] pedophiles and
love to play with you thought about
podcasting yeah yep talk about y'all put
them in [__] the importancy out when
they get a present to choose a good
restaurant you know I love you my buddy
I would never pimp you out not to do sex
acts but but touchin old man's balls
what's the difference guys laughing
touches boys don't like ever experience
doing no I'll put it Betty buddy yeah
you know me
listen I've caught charging 350 you get
to 50 and you get security and you walk
in andra dollars because I'm telling you
I'm providing the security the booking
what nobody's gonna hit you in the head
and stick and pick up your ass and leave
you in prison and I'm gonna make sure
they just go in there watch TV with him
he wants to do what's that not like one
of you one of you a security guy who
wants to stick it up my butt hoo-wee
I don't know why you let's say you go
into the old man shed and an inmate
comes up to me and says Joey how much
would a cute little Jew I asked him what
do you want to do I want everything
around the world a alyssum I do don't do
around the world she's a virgin
well I'll let you do is I haven't pulled
his pants down and you could jerk off on
his butt cheek and he'll be like a reach
around his old nutsack that's as far as
he goes really well he really scratched
his balls from behind he goes to yoga
three times a day he's a guru you can't
tell by looking at a fine colony as a
kid and I can't stop being cheeseburgers
but he's our eyes besides I would get
three bills how do we get 750 for you to
bend over holes ankles and from three
feet away from that whack off and with
his hands just probably come at your ass
that's it
and afterward when your ass is wiped you
can hug him and tell your love and
that's it
752 of those a day that's 1,500 five
days a week
are you [__] kidding me that's good
money man Justin you'll find me you'll
say I don't want to work on the podcast
no more that's a lot of [__] cash Lee
oh that's like that's like [__]
that's like 15,000 every two weeks at
30,000 a month
no sex Brendon Overland guys what do we
call it what's the website I don't know
there's no website know what how do we
market it
this is an imaginary character in case I
ever went to prison and things got bad
we ran out of loot you don't mean we're
partners I would go behind bars maybe
sell some coke we have to do things but
if the old you and make comes up to me
and says us and your friend he's kind of
cute can we work so much better shave
your beard and we're a militant suit
listen for small 350 my friend do
whatever the [__] you need bacon 350
because I'm listening
not enough to do what the another 350 to
bend over and have a guy do that is
disgusting anything involved no no no
the other one when you serve his lap and
watch TV for a half-hour his balls
listen what you're not touching his
balls you're looking the other way your
balances I know if you used to grab his
balls by mistake to pull you back up and
give him a smile and may believe you
watch the baseball game again I hope it
loves baseball it's not a crazy person
this is a [__] best conversation ever
he was thinking about imaginary
situations okay you're my brother I'm
not in the business to pimp you out
you're my little brother hello I gotta
look out for you
I know dick cyan I know your mother I
know the boss over there patron that's
what you call it now right I heard you
call the other day when I called you
like hold on hold on I'll patron oh this
equal open show now is [__] or not
we were walking Julian you bad
[__]
what something can ask I congratulate
you for your success this last little
leg of the tour will you read these [__]
yeah hey can I can i film it [__] yeah
let me explain something to you so what
is the lots for shows what are you gonna
do after this but your plans after I
think I'm gonna do another record ok
yeah yeah that's what most people do
yeah I didn't figure we're gonna end it
with these we're gonna blow it out the
end of the year for Big Show's West
Coast and hopefully you and Leo come to
LA show you don't want them elective
December 10 don't know if I miss a
comment all the week after who the [__]
knows any more thing yeah it changes
every [__] two weeks if I do this I
might have to wear glasses all right so
don't get pissed off and oh yeah I can
see it from here you know me I'm a
[__] bad [__] are you ready
one two all right are you ready one two
here you go
we love Walker's juniors we love
Walker's we love Walker Julia's last
shows of the year are the biggest shows
ever they understand me it's all we love
Walker the [__] King doing his [__]
thing on sale now [__] and if you
show up ladies watch that monkey he
don't like dirty stinky monkeys he likes
[__] flip-flop anyway sorry that
stuff to the top we'll do it afterward
don't worry we'll do it afterward and
then we'll make it happen free will do
it afterward trust I kind of like that
no no you don't like it that I gotta
have glasses let me review it okay and
now I'll put a spin on it I don't like
it I [__] love it you know I'm
[__] nuts dawg I don't [__] around I
love you to death for the people at home
maybe there's plain and simple alright
here's my brother here you've heard him
on a bunch of podcasts but most
importantly you've heard his [__]
music and you know he ain't [__]
around this ain't some guy that goes up
there like Jimmy Fallon those dirty so I
have nothing against Jimmy Fallon god
bless his mother and my condolences to
his family I'm just saying this is not a
guy that goes up there and just plays a
guitar and sells out here with a couple
dirty words you heard his [__] story
near her was going on Melissa
it gets better it gets better
[__] cuz we will walk to Julius
last shows of the year his biggest shows
effort do you understand me it's all
wheeler the [__] King on sale right now
today no more [__] stories all right
you're gonna go out with your family
you're gonna go over you're gonna eat
Thanksgiving and have a good time you'll
eat the jelly and again three pounds and
that's in the party starts you know what
because we the walk over being [__]
down
that [__] following week there's
nothing like going to a concert after
Thanksgiving when grandmother's your
savings bonds that's $55 in the
shoreland so the kids you gotta get rid
of it to go see my man wheeler Walker
Julius last shows of the year here it is
nice and simple ready December 3rd in
Los Angeles at the [__] novo
December 4th Santa Barbara's birthday
for the Cuban people San Diego at the
observatory in North Park and here you
go December 5th Santa Ana Santa Ana
Santa Ana at the [__]
observatory a different one so bring the
[__] three big glasses of the 18 of
them you can look at the Stars and play
with yourself and then December 6
you got Phoenix at the [__] Van
Buren neither dot dot time that's the
wheel of Walker jr. [__] light up if
you don't go to those shows listen I
might stab you in the [__] neck
personally that's how I roll [__]
go see my brother ok you in listen if
you're a [__] girl and you listen to
this and you want to get closer to your
boyfriend get him a [__] ticket four
wheeler walk what is he gonna do with
your money you're sitting at home if
you're Lee's girlfriend Lee wants to go
and he wants to spend 700 on tickets he
wants a top that's [__] thinking
telling me you don't [__] around you
want to park right in front of the joint
and have a [__] car seeing walk
inside only the best
especially for wheel Walker and while
we're talking about a wife walk around
anymore right let me talk to you about
something seriously or any other love
because the holidays are coming the new
years are coming and already wants to
eat a little bit [__] healthier we
all want to eat better we all want to
eat healthier but when it comes to
snacks
you know it feels like that the whole
world is delicious and it'll talk ten
million calories versus what you want to
eat an arm and whether in any way boring
and tasteless it doesn't have to be that
way up your snack game with nature box
the understanding nature box has over a
hundred snacks that taste good and
actually better for you all snacks are
made from high-quality simple
ingredients which means no artificial
colors flavors or sweeteners no guilt no
nothing so you can feel good about what
you're eating my favorites or the
chocolate nom noms the praline pumpkin
seeds the raw almonds the roasted salted
almonds listen the list goes on and on
they got some stuff that kills and made
the understanding and sometimes they're
all the same stuff and sometimes I take
a chance like the crispy coconut squares
or the double chocolate brownie cookies
or the vanilla bean wafers you have no
idea my wife and my daughter tear those
[__] up like somebody from a
third world nation eating this law a
turkey for the first time or whatever
the [__] it is the sea salt pop pops the
coffee catalyst the list goes on and on
and on all right do me a favor you're
sure to find your new snack obsession at
nature box they add new snacks every
month inspired by real customer feedback
like yours on the latest food trends and
professional chefs so it's simple go-to
naturebox.com/tyler one and naturebox
will deliver them you ready for this one
right to your door all right
nobody knows nuttin it's on the
up-and-up don't be there within days and
there's no risk if you try a snack you
don't like don't eat it nature box will
replace it for free now here's our words
there's no I'm gonna do for you today
the nature box is off in the church
what's happening now family right now
today 50% off your first order
when you go to nature box college or
again that snakes and bugs coms last
Joey for 50% off your first daughter
that's half delivered to your door no
games
naturebox calm I want to
thank my brother we love Walker Julia
for coming in here and dropping
knowledge and my main little
[__] well I would never pimp
out this is just uh I've been watching
too much of that prison Chinese I'm
saying I'm sorry it got away from me
thank you again for having my favorite
show is you're my [__] family this is
this I love you guy there was a pleasure
showing you those videos let you know
the mental state oh I just love the
podcast just Washington lot it's just
like watching your favorite show a lot
it's like this is this is this is
Skynyrd for me well I appreciate that my
brother thank you again don't forget
next Tuesday the Comedy Store link
should be up eight o'clock show listen
we need to [__] the paratroopers
there I need to look a little there you
understand me the [__] way
[__] around down there Leo be there
we got stars we got explosives it's
going to be a [__] good night
worst-case scenario a little taking to
eat hummus but that's none of my
business I don't want to know about it
I love your [__] I love we love
walking against supporters tour you're
doing a website cuz
yeah we're walking Jeannie calm BAM
there you go we love Walker Judy dot-com
stop [__] around
my brother Lee kick that [__]
meal it's Tuesday morning [__]
thank you for listening to the church